[Music]
this week 48 hours looks at a woman from
washington state who had a surprising
role in solving a cold case chelsea
rustad wanted to learn more about her
family tree so she uploaded her dna to a
genealogy website but she never imagined
that there was a killer in her family
tree 48 hours correspondent erin
moriarty explains how her dna helped
craft a decades-old cold case in just
two hours
did you have any idea
just what kind of story your dna would
tell
i really didn't i just had no inkling at
all that there were secret relatives i
didn't know about or mysteries to
uncover
when chelsea rustad uploaded her dna on
a public database she never expected two
police investigators would appear on her
doorstep they let me know that they are
investigating a family member of mine
for murder a double homicide from 1987.
this was a person who was in my family
tree for more than 30 years
investigators in washington state have
been trying to solve the murders of 18
year old tanya van kylenburg and her 20
year old boyfriend jay cook it was
probably the most horrendous unsolved
case that we had
cold case detective jim sharp
this was a person who was a real
predator and it was believed at the time
that it was probably a serial killer or
an ex-convict but the killer's identity
remained a mystery until dna evidence
found on tanya's pants was uploaded to
the same website that contained chelsea
rustad's dna
enabling genetic genealogist cece moore
to identify the likely suspect in just
two hours
that's the power of genetic genealogy
did that name appear on any of the
suspects list
no
that name had never been
across my desk ever but did scharf have
the right man genetic genealogy has
exposed a lot of secrets that
people had hoped would remain secret yes
oftentimes it's someone's deepest
darkest secret genetic genealogy finding
your roots aaron moriarty joins us right
now aaron good morning so why didn't the
police find this suspect sooner well
they were looking for a predator they
they thought he had had a rape murder
kit and what genetic genealogy is
showing us is kind of an uh maybe a new
kind of killer in this case the suspect
had no criminal history
so now they're thinking that maybe some
of these killers kill once and then
never again he was living under the
radar he never would have been found out
if not for his two second cousins who
uploaded their dna this really is the
future
i mean game changer sounds like oh yeah
this guy didn't fit the profile they
were not at all and the fact that this
was a
30-plus year mystery they had all these
suspects and then cece moore in two
hours
finds a suspect
um it's it's fascinating to talk about a
new theory for who and what a killer can
be that's fascinating stuff
how common are these breakthroughs so
far with genealogy well i was surprised
in the last three years cece moore has
has found a suspect in a hundred and
sixty unsolved murders and it's also
being used for missing people um the
john and jane does so in 30 of those
cases it's definitely the future but
there's some real privacy i was going to
say doesn't
upload my dna and find out more about
where i came from my ancestors should i
be hesitant this is a real question
coming from me off script right now
because i'm concerned about my privacy
and here's why a lot of states do not
have any regulations and we can all
agree isn't that great when they find a
killer of course but what if police
start using it to find who went to a
protest there's dna there so or for
lesser crime i think that's the real
privacy concern i think that's the
entire i'd hesitate conversation i would
have you would you would hesitate yeah i
would i would maybe we'll talk about
that another time thank you so much all
right now you can watch aaron's report a
killer in the family tree on 48 hours
tomorrow night at 10 9 central right
here on cbs